Russian troops continue to Shell the
city of Harrison recaptured by Ukrainian
forces but that's shelling the governor
there says has killed three people in
this latest round of attacks on the
region and the winter cold is adding to
the misery MTS tayab has a harsh look
now or a look now at the harsh
conditions and the efforts to help the
people survive
for her son's City's cold and desperate
a Lifeline warming stations have been
set up around the main square and is
where we met 85 year old Dina you're
covered in blood
she tells us how she fell and cut her
hand but is grateful she was able to
come here to get warm band-aged up and
have her coat men
three weeks after Ukrainian forces
liberated her son City from nine brutal
months of Russian occupation residents
are still in need of the basics
including contact with the outside world
this portable 4G cell phone tower was
brought in so people could make calls
but food Aid is also desperately needed
despite the risks in trying to get it
that hasn't stopped these professors
from a university and key for bringing
in these supplies
it's for colleagues at the hersan
National University who they hadn't been
able to make contact with for months
because Russian soldiers controlled
their lives so tightly remnants of
Russian's occupation have been swept
into this room you can see Flags photos
of Vladimir Putin and while Russian
forces are gone make no mistake they're
still targeting this city
ever since their humiliating retreat
Moscow has been hammering her son
relentlessly
it's a misery Anastasia an instructor at
the University knows all too well it's
so cold you have no electricity you have
no heating you have no water
Freedom yeah Freedom this is more value
for us
but that freedom is far from guaranteed
as Russia continues to pound her son
devastating its energy grid but as we've
been hearing people say they'd rather
live without food water or heat than
live under Russian occupation again for
CBS mornings
her son Ukraine